alors vous rencontrez en 2018 Ingrid et
vous mettez secrètement en couple avec
elle oui ça commence comme ça bien sûr
alors comme vous l'avez connu bah dans
un quelque chose de très ordinaire pour
un prêtre c'est un baptême ouais
d'accord lors d'un baptême et donc là
c'est quoi le coup de foudre pas tout de
suite il y a d'abord une amitié entre
nous et puis voilà on commence à se
connaître et puis au bout d'un moment
bien l'amour arrive mais c'est Ingrid
surtout qui fait le premier pas ah ouais
Ingrid vous vous avez tout de suite sur
kiffé Marc tout de suite peut-être pas
mais très vite
donc qu'est-ce que vous avez fait parce
que vous êtes pas dit tout de suite
c'est impossible c'est voilà que là j'ai
choisi la mauvaise personne
d'autant plus que moi j'étais encore
mariée
histoire épineuse
donc là vous êtes marié avec le père de
vos enfants
vous rencontrez Marc un baptême au
départ c'est de l'amitié ah bah oui donc
à partir de quel moment vous avez senti
que c'était plus de l'amitié
je dirai rien
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
je vais le faire
non mais où dans quel endroit
au presbytère
j'ai invité Ingrid à prendre un thé et
puis à la fin du thé elle vous embrasse
et vous avez fait quoi vous
je me suis laissé faire déjà
et puis Ingrid part vous n'êtes pas dit
je suis dans une merde de noir alors
c'est elle qui dit excuse-moi faut
oublier tout voilà on a fait une erreur
etc et puis moi je dis bah écoute faut
vivre ça faut accueillir ça et et pour
moi c'est le début d'un nouveau chemin
c'est beau je me dis bien sûr ça va être
compliqué mais ce qui est premier c'est
l'amour voilà c'est incroyable
franchement c'est magnifique et donc là
qu'est-ce que vous faites bah là je
commence à réfléchir un peu je me dis ça
va être compliqué quand même parce que
c'est une institution qui a du mal à
envisager qu'après de tombe amoureux et
et je me dis assez vite finalement on se
dit je vais pas rester caché je veux pas
que c'était mon se cacher donc je
choisis tous les deux finalement de se
dire bah on va vivre notre amour au
grand jour on a été un peu obligé parce
que il y a une petite lettre anonyme qui
a été envoyé
[Musique]
[Rires]
le truc c'est qu'on veut nous faire
culpabiliser et donc moi assez vite et
je pense Ingrid m'a beaucoup aidé
m'a dit il y a aucune culpabilité à
avoir d'aimer et d'être aimé donc moi
assez vite je me dis bah arrête de te
sentir coupable
c'est pas c'est pas un péché que d'aimer
puisque c'est une religion qui dit
aimez-vous les uns les autres comme je
vous ai aimé donc et et et en vivant je
me dis bah
j'arrêtais pas de prêcher aimez-vous
aimez-vous et puis là bah enfin je le
vis donc c'est un carnet ce qu'ils ont
dit vos proches mes proches a été un
petit peu compliqué au départ voilà
parce qu'il me voyait en prêtre un rôle
sacré quasi sacré etc et puis bah d'été
voilà plus souvent
non
c'est ce qui est bon pour toi sois
heureuse et là vous avez l'air très
heureux et oui franchement alors
franchement moi je trouve rayonnant
marque Ingrid aussi et
Ingrid Ingrid je la sens déterre vous
vous étiez déterminé
vraiment ah ouais vouliez vous battre
pour Marc qu'est-ce qui s'est passé vous
avez vu quoi pour lui dire c'est lui
23 ans de vie très compliquée
sentimentale chaotique oui avec des
violences et donc du coup voilà et donc
moi les hommes je voulais plus trop on
entend parler en fait
[Musique]
inaccessible bien entendu on s'est
compris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je présume rien de l'avenir mais c'est
assez violent quand même c'est
[Musique]
ça on sent un rejet quoi c'est fort et
moi je me dis mais en fait j'aime
je j'ai prêché l'amour pendant des
années et d'un seul coup on me dit c'est
la porte alors que en plus voilà il y a
des choses cachées dans cette
institution qui sont inavoués etc et que
et que nous on assume on le vit au grand
jour et là donc ça a été violent donc ça
c'est quoi les gens
qui sont tous les jours il y en a un et
qui explose et moi je me dis bah on veut
vivre quelque chose de ça entre deux
études consentants et là on se fait
jeter donc bah c'est c'est violent
faites quoi dans la vie bon aujourd'hui
je conseille je fais du conseil en
management donc je conseille
d'entreprise
c'est mon père
il a pris des cours de piano parce que
j'ai jamais joué
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et que vous avez choisi Marc ça me va
parce que là je voudrais pas que ça me
fasse d'histoire oui oui vous n'avez
jamais pensé que comme les pasteurs par
exemple qui continuent à être des hommes
de Dieu quand une femme et des enfants
et qui respecte les deux choses cette
énergie de changer de crémerie quoi
j'aimerais bien que l'institution d'où
je viens se rendre compte qu'il faut
changer des choses après c'est c'est un
vieux bateau qui a du mal à évoluer il y
aura
un peu branlant et et j'espère que bah
il y en a de temps en temps qui qui sort
qui tombent amoureux mais qu'on se dise
bah il y a peut-être quelque chose à
changer quoi les missionnaires dont on
manque terriblement le le un peu
branlant
est-ce que chez vous un petit moment
vous continuez à prier justement ou pas
oui est-ce que ça vous a un peu
refroidit sur tout ça bah c'est assez
intérieur oui c'est c'est plus c'est
plus personnel c'est plus donc c'est
l'institution en fait que vous enfin
vous êtes déçu de l'institution mais
votre foie n'a pas n'a pas bougé pour
autant la profondeur il y a une relation
il y a un désir d'absolu il y a bien
sinon il y a mon père qui est médecin
est-ce que vous êtes plus heureux
maintenant ou avant dites la vérité
quoi rien à voir rien à voir rien à voir
rien à voir
vraiment
ça tu vois je comprends que tu es un
coup de foudre pour une fille
pour Ingrid
es non mais c'est vrai que elle voit
qu'elle est elle a quelque chose
pour rayonner tous les deux en tout cas
bien sûr en tout cas ça vous avez pas eu
le sentiment de de trahir voilà de
traire
l'institution de trahir parce que la
religion est-ce que l'amour est plus
fort que la religion oui c'est à dire
que normalement l'amour devrait être au
coeur de la religion est amour mais
c'est les institutions qui les
trahissent en fait vous êtes abandonné
par l'institution exactement c'est
hypocrite c'est rétrograde vous savez
que la réponse du Vatican elle est quand
même assez minable si je peux me
permettre
tous ces gens là qui branlent rien eux
n'ont plus que calme-toi un peu
non mais là tu peux pas dire ça alors je
dois dire ça non mais là tu peux pas
dire ça là tu es marié pour aller loin
on peut pas tu peux pas pourquoi il
refuse de non mais je suis catholique
oui mais quand même communion j'ai tout
fait mais ils disent simplement au
Vatican que il refuse le mariage des
prêtres uniquement pour que vous soyez
plus disponible pour vos fidèles c'est
ça c'est aberrant comme réponse
totalement on est à témoignage il y a
pas longtemps d'un couple que j'ai
préparé au mariage et il disait à Ingrid
d'ailleurs bah on était déjà ensemble il
disait bah Marc qui nous parle de de
l'amour de manière on a l'impression que
il le vit quoi il savait pas il savait
pas ce qu'on était en fait
ils ont sorti un truc mais il le savait
pas donc il savait pas que c'est
c'était vous aviez eu des meufs avant
son prix en fait
ce qu'on appelle
non mais c'est vrai
et après et donc et après vous avez et
après je me voilà c'est comme c'était
combien de temps vous êtes ensemble
et 4 ans
moi je vous trouve magnifique moi je
vous kiffe magnifique
et vous avez l'air rayonnant amoureux
tous les deux souriants et vous avez des
épiderme magnifique
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]